the early days of the pandemic online
virtual learning it was perhaps an
acceptable stop gap for a very short
period of time
for schools as we learn more about
kovitz potency or
rather lack thereof when it came to
children but a year of virtual learning
has taken a terrible toll on the kids
many are learning virtually nothing
and falling through the cracks our own
raymond arroyo spoke to one family in
the audience tonight
who's struggling with this very issue
laura when you think of the toll virtual
learning has taken on children
few consider special needs students i'm
here in alexandria virginia where
patrick williamson
a 10 year old boy who lives in this
neighborhood has been stuck in front of
a screen
for the better part of a year and as his
mother guadalupe told me
it has taken a severe toll on him
personally
emotionally it's been very hard for him
to be home without friends
with his teachers he loves his teachers
they're great and it's just
hard for him that he has to see them
through the computer
do you feel it's lonely doing it this
way
yes right before the pandemic he was
already started to read
one syllable words and and he was
already counting to 100
and i really really had the hope that
by now he will be reading sentences it's
sad i mean
he he became very quiet um sad andre he
now i mean he even his words it's
almost like they're gone and he doesn't
know what to say anymore what's the
hardest part
learning it's hard to learn at home yes
why
but because learning at school
and you like the contact right you can
touch
things at school and you can be in touch
with your teachers personally
yes is it easier for you to learn that
way yes
fairfax county public schools recently
offered patrick
the possibility of returning to school
with no other students and without
an in-person teacher the only thing we
can provide for him is a computer
for him to be there in school by himself
from nine to four pm with a classroom
monitor
and this person is gonna be in four pp
six
feet apart and just make sure
that the kids alive throughout the day
and that's it
who comes up with these ideas that it's
okay to have a child with special needs
from nine to four all by himself sitting
down in front of a computer
and that's just a viable option somehow
i know your brother goes to a local
school and he
he was he was able to go to school but
you couldn't
did that make you upset yes what did you
tell your mom when you saw him go to
school and you couldn't
i wanted to go to school for guadalupe
the school board's lack of concern for
her child's welfare
has pushed her to the breaking point
fairfax county supports to be
one of the best schools in the nation
and taxes should pay for it we have a
big family for kids
two adults and and we could live in a
bigger house but we want to live here in
a smaller house because
you get everything else and you get the
fairfax county public schools
but now it feels like it's not worth it
i want to thank guadalupe who's here in
the audience for sharing her family's
story with us tonight